men are in their soft guy era ladies
so you better be ready to step it up
he needs a haircut
you better offer to pay
send him a Venmo so he can get a fresh cut
he's at the golf course
well buy him and his boys a round of drinks
send him that Venmo
he needs a car wash
well offer to detail his car or take his car through the car wash
he's hungry, make him or buy him food
make sure you prepare him food that has extra protein
guys love protein
and love to be surprised with gifts just like women do
so does he want a new car part
buy him a new car part
pretty much just gift wrap him a gift that you think he will like
he's tired, let him take a nap on the couch
He doesn’t want to do yard work or mow the lawn
offer to pay for a gardener
these are easy things that you could do to help your man
be in his soft guy era
men are now understanding their worth
it's time to step it up if you want your man to stay
drizzle drizzle